c'est une recette désormais approuvés et
testés pour cette nouvelle édition du
festival métal sphère l'ambition reste
inchangée découvrir ou redécouvrir ce
qu'ils font la scène métal française et
locale pour le plus grand plaisir de ses
fans du genre moi c'est la première fois
ici je suis pas du tout du coin mais
franchement ça me plait énormément c'est
super sympa et puis bizarrement moi ça
m'apaise cette musique donc franchement
je me suis senti super bien j'aime
beaucoup
très très cool la salle de la tour pour
hier très bonnes salles et voilà
toujours une ambiance au top mais tu as
au génial deux jours de concerts sept
groupes à la fiche parmi eux
bukowski formé par une fratrie il y à 13
ans le groupe de rock métal vivait sa
première au festival métal ce faire
c'est la première fois qu'on vient ici
j'avais entendu parler souvent de cette
salle
et puis l'accueil est super en plus on
est content parce qu'on joue avec notre
poteau de lofofora pour la deuxième
année consécutive le festival s'est
déployée hors de ses murs historique
situé salle de la torah voisins le
bretonneux la salle la batterie à
guyancourt était elle aussi partenaire
de l'événement la notion de territoire à
l'est quand même très importante
ce qu'on essaye vraiment d'être actif
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
et justement le projet c'est de pouvoir
développer ce festival métal plus
largement sur le territoire c'est pour
les années à venir pourquoi pas avoir
une semaine métal sphères où un mois un
peu à métal se faire avant la 10e
édition de métal se faire l'an prochain
les fans de métal de saint quentin en
yvelines ont d'abord rendez vous pour la
doublette faire en avril et le festival
la tour mais les watts en juin prochain
[Musique]